why don't you explain what laplace's
demon is and then why there's an
impossibility result about the existence
of laplace's demon
okay
um not surprisingly laplace's demon is
named for a simon laplace
worked towards the end of the 18th
century mostly the early 19th century
he was among other things the first
person to really use bayesian statistics
he applied it to planetary motion
to try to infer what the actual um true
or
make more accurate estimates of the true
parameters of the motion of the planets
is
um a whole bunch of
mathematics
that we use that undergraduates will be
using in
the physics and math majors and so on
has his name involved so he's a very
very bright guy
now he was
working at a time when people thought
that everything was ultimately newtonian
classical physics
well before relativity well before
quantum mechanics
and
he
realized that in that paradigm
if you give a um a brilliant scientist
or a demon
sufficient information about these state
of the world at present
they can predict exactly what the state
of the world would be in all of its
details arbitrarily far into the future
and this was true before um not only
many notions of quantum mechanics or
relativity but also before people knew
about chaos or any of the other
kinds of phenomena that have been
uncovered in the 20th century that might
make one think that the apostles demon
can't quite hold
um
so that's his demon one
the work that i've been involved with on
inference devices
one of the it's almost kind of a trivial
but one of the kinds of things that it
uncovers
is that regardless of what actually the
laws of physics are
um regardless of whether it's got
anything to do with what's currently
called the standard model whether it's
quantum physics
um whether it's classical physics it
could have been newtonian it could have
been newtonian where there was no chaos
it could have been exactly the paradigm
that laplace was thinking in
but even given that kind of a
hypothesis
his demon could not exist there's a
logical fallacy
embedded in the very notion
um and that is actually intuitively it's
quite simple you can set it up in terms
of um
what's sometimes called a cretins liars
paradox some people say
epimenides
was the person who first wrote it down
others say it actually um has earlier
roots still
but um basically you can set it up in
such a way that
they're um even in a classical universe
where it's a finite one even let's make
it be finite with no chaos you can very
easily um construct
possible questions concerning the future
state of that universe
that laplace could not possibly get
correct
by definition whatever his prediction is
it would be exactly wrong
precisely because laplace is part of the
universe that is the key
um so it's not too hard to convince
yourself of why that might be true
and
we can work through the details if you
want
i don't know how you might actually get
this out to your audience
but um there's
um some work
i can show a slide later you can just
send me those
yeah maybe we can do that later um
yeah let's get to all that later um
so in any case the um
so that is part of a general inference
device devices really grew out of
the desire to quantify and build a
formal structure
that goes beyond this impossibility
argument of apostle demon which by the
way i have not actually proven it to you
but certainly not the generality that i
stated it about how it's impossible
where it doesn't depend on the laws of
physics
so what inference devices is about that
whole formalism
at root what it says when it first
notices is that um
let's go for let's adopt the one
attribute of reality
that most card carrying physicists
certainly cosmologists
would ascribe to
independent of the detailed physical
theory which is that the human beings
themselves are physical systems
so this is so it's really a perspective
that turns conventional philosophy on
its head
in that um rather than try to understand
what various
um what our scientific theories might be
um in terms of well
are we just discovering the external
reality or
like an instrumentalist would say we're
discovering useful variables for making
predictions about the external reality
and so on
instead to practicing physicists as i
said especially those who deal with for
example cosmology
rather
physical reality is the starting point
and then you derive human beings
as an approximation to some of the
equations and physics of that of the
actual true world
so to whatever degree
those
epi phenomena of human beings
can themselves make accurate theories
about this physical system they're
embedded with that's a secondary
question
so rather than starting from the
perspective of humans
saying what um
what is it that we're talking about when
we talk about science how does it relate
to the external reality
the physicists make that be a very very
secondary minor question saying let's
start with the physical reality
then human beings are just one of the
phenomena in that physical reality that
we can describe completely
and if we wanted to we could drill down
into even more um my newt
semi-trivial questions like well some of
those human beings they call themselves
philosophers of science
and they're looking at these various
things that other human beings called
scientists that come up with
and they're trying to worry about how
they might relate to this underlying
physical reality and yet that's all well
and good but it's
very very secondary to the presumption
that
physical reality is just the set of
mathematical questions and we humans and
all of our
conundrums are just something that comes
out from it
so
if you adopt that perspective
then you can go very very
broad scale on some of the issues that
are addressed in philosophy of science
and associate branches of philosophy
called epistemology
you can say
given any agent doesn't have to be a
human being that is
situated in that physical reality
so the states of its brain are simply a
subset of uh they only
how to phrase it so the physical reality
to allow it to have any kinds of laws
we will reduce it to a set which is the
set of all possible
histories of reality through all time
what is called a world line in
relativity
so
um
there's going to be one world line
in which you curt are wearing a um a red
off-reddish jacket
there's another world line that would be
the same laws of physics but it's
another element in the set in which
you're right now wearing instead of more
brownish jacket
these are both world lines
that are elements of the set of all
possible world line histories
so if i then look at the particular
world line in which kurt is sitting in
that so if i look at the particular
event that kurt is right now sitting in
that chair
that actually selects out a subset of
all possible world lines
there will be some in which you are
sitting in that chair and someone which
you are not
so that event is really just a subset of
the set of all possible world lines of
the universe
in addition
the um event where you pose to yourself
a question like
what happens when um two bodies that are
gravitationally attracted to one another
and have the following masses of
momentum come within a certain distance
of one another the set of realities in
which you pose that question
is a subset of all possible world lines
the set of realities in which you give a
possible particular answer to that
question
is another subset
and also we can presume that the set of
physical realities in which your answer
is correct
and which your answer is wrong
are yet other subsets
so what this sets up
so to speak um is that there's a
relationship between these sets where
one subset of all the realities where
you pose a question
another one is where you give a
particular answer both of which are just
physical states of your brain and then
there's a third one which has to do with
the actual
physical system you are asking this
question about
the answer to your question may in some
of those describe that physical system
accurately and they may do it
inaccurately they might be wrong in
other words
it turns out that just by making that
decomposition that
everything about you are making a
prediction
is it involves questions answers and
truths
we can also say everything about you're
making an observation you are right now
observing
something
which you can be then posing a question
to yourself what am i observing
you can then have an answer to that what
am i um what do i think in response to
that question
and then it can be the actual truth and
these again are just three subsets of
all possible world lines
whether your observation is correct or
is distorted
will be determined by the overlap
between these world lines
so everything you observe
everything you predict
everything that you remember which is
another example of this
everything you can control you could
reach out your hand and try to be having
the question
where is this pencil going to be
one minute from now and you are making
it so
anything in this most broad sense
imaginable of what in philosophy is
called epistemology of you of your
knowledge
about this world about whether your
knowledge could be correct or could be
or wrong
we can reduce all analysis of it
to saying how is it that these three
subsets
um relate to one another
based upon that so notice that this
level of formalism we're far beyond any
specifics like is it a universe where
quantum mechanics holds or classical
mechanics hold the universe could be
finite the universe could not have chaos
on it it doesn't matter
nor does it matter how you are
making your
questions and answers whether it be by
prediction predicting whether the sun
will come up tomorrow or on what's going
to be happening with those two
gravitation gravitating bodies i
alluded to before or if it comes via
observation or even memory
or directly control any form of these is
being covered by the structure of three
overlapping subsets
it turns out that once you do that that
all that is needed is that
formalism of three overlapping subsets
that you can get a whole bunch of
impossibility results
and one of them to return to the point
that you were raising before has to do
with apostles demon